[Musica]
no scusate perché questo è importante
niente spero che non vi stati offesi se
ero al cellulare perché immagino che
potevate offendervi è una cosa che dà
molto fastidio quando sei una persona
state conversando e questa tira fuori il
cellulare magari avete il tempo solo per
un caffè o per un toast veloce si mette
a messaggiare come se quello che voi
state dicendo è meno importante di
quello che c'è scritto su questo
cellulare
siamo in un epoca in cui lo smartphone
si connette di e ci permette di essere
connessi 24 ore su 24 in rete quindi con
i nostri social network e abbiamo
whatsapp è che ci permette di comunicare
gratuitamente e mandare un sacco di
emoticon colorate oppure ci sono anche
le gif adesso non so se voi usate le gif
ma se volete usare una jeep ci mettete
almeno 30 minuti per scegliere quella
più adatta alla vostra conversazione e
questo non è un problema che riguarda
solo i giovani che sono di solito quelli
più distratti ma è un problema globale è
un problema di tutti perché anche gli
adulti lo fanno anche anche i nonni lo
fanno perché pure gli ultrasettantenni
oggi hanno uno smartphone e anche
bambini otto anni hanno già uno
smartphone yo yo anche lo faccio
purtroppo ci cado pure io
e ogni volta che mi succede mi chiedo
perchè perchè non riusciamo a rimanere
concentrati sul nostro momento presente
dobbiamo andare a cercare questa
distrazione così futile mi sono risposta
di me risposte sono che probabilmente
quello che stiamo si stanno dicendo non
è abbastanza interessante andiamo a
cercare nel cellulare qualcosa che
stimoli un po di più il nostro
divertimento
oppure quello che ci stanno dicendo è
troppo è troppo pesante perché oggi ci
sono tanti argomenti che ci fanno stare
un po scomodi no noi ci vogliono far
uscire dalla nostra confusione noi non
ci sentiamo così pronti di metterci in
gioco oppure
è lo stress della vita quotidiana dal
quale vogliamo scappare
siamo sempre tutti di corsa abbiamo
tanti impegni con le persone con lavoro
e cerchiamo nel cellulare un qualcosa di
più leggero di un po più frivolo come la
messaggistica
ultima ma non ultima è forse il fatto
che non riusciamo più tra di noi a
comunicare come facevamo una volta
guardandoci negli occhi e le persone
oggi ad esempio le coppie si lasciano
anche per messaggio oppure magari volete
aggiornare la vostra famiglia oi vostri
amici su come va la vostra vita e
passate 20 minuti a registrare una nota
vocale che l'altra persona si ascolterà
quando potevate far partire una chiamata
ascoltare la loro voce oppure magari
accordarvi per per un appuntamento sulla
base di questo io ho detto come si può
fare per sistemare questa situazione che
secondo me andando avanti così diventerà
veramente drastica quale può essere la
soluzione è la risposta mi è arrivata in
realtà al tavolo di un ristorante perché
io dovete sapere che organizzo
organizzava organizzo cene con delitto
quindi ha unito la mia passione della
recitazione con quella della scrittura
ho cominciato con la mia compagna
teatrale a fare queste azioni con
delitto i copioni m'iscrivevo io perché
ho la fortuna di avere un papà che mi ha
stimolato moltissimo anche il nostro
gioco principale e reinventare favole e
lui mi mi ha fatto crescere così tanto
la crea di creatività e io quindi mi
diverta divertivo moltissimo a scrivere
questi copioni e anche chi giocava si
divertiva con tantissimo si divertiva
così tanto che quando gli investigati
erano al loro tavolo i commissari
commensali si dimenticavano del
cellulare addirittura diventava un
disturbo e veniva spostato messo in
borsa ha messo via e mi sono detta ecco
ecco la risposta ecco come si può fare a
mantenere le persone prese le persone
presenti ea farle dimenticare che hanno
delle spie lampeggianti sul cellulare
con il gioco e ho capito che questa era
un'idea troppo grande per poterla
mantenere all'interno
ristorante io volevo che più persone
delle 50 60 che sono seduti al tavolo
potessero giocare e ho detto come posso
fare
lo porto all'esterno ma porta in centro
di una città
lo faccio diventare fuori in modo che
chiunque possa partecipare quindi ho
preso come idea miss mia fa mi ha
stimolato il credo che non so se voi lo
conoscete ma al ruedo è un gioco è stato
la un poliziesco perché siamo tutti non
ci piace un po investigare su chi è la
colpa
proprio ho scritto nel nostro dna che
vogliamo sapere chi come dove quando
perché in modo che noi ci laviamo di
dosso la responsabilità di trovare delle
soluzioni i nostri problemi insomma
hanno fatto diventare vivente cioè o ci
ho messo degli attori in carne ed ossa
al posto dei personaggi e come poi nel
gioco in scatola
bisogna investigare su chi ha ucciso il
dottor black che arma utilizzato in
quale stanza commesso il crimine con
questo io sono riuscito a risolvere quei
problemi che vi ho elencato prima
andiamo a vedere come con la
condivisione perché per giocare alcune
do vivente sud vedi la pubblicità e vuoi
fare la tua squadra deve almeno avere 6
10 amici che partecipano con the queen
devi metterti a telefonare e se non li
raggiungi ferrai unito un'altra squadra
piccola quindi è un ottimo modo per fare
amicizia con persone sconosciute
competizione
allora per vincere al ruedo vivente
bisogna essere bravi e rapidi quindi non
c'è nessuno che si perde sono tutti
svegli attivi perché vogliono vincere e
quindi la la noia e l'apatia se ne vanno
via
divertimento e leggerezza dunque per
arrivare alla soluzione del cluedo
vivente ci sono delle prove da fare
niente di complicato io ho messo insieme
tutto quello che è la mia esperienza di
vita ho messo insieme st autismo gruppi
famiglia caccia al tesoro giochi di
ruolo le case le cene con delitto ed ho
creato delle prove che possono essere ad
esempio
disegnare cantare raccogliere degli
oggetti tutte cose che fanno normalmente
i bambini quindi una maniera molto
leggera e molto divertente
dunque io quando ho iniziato a pensare
al ruedo vivente lavorava come impiegata
in un'azienda edile che non era quello
che volevo fare
però mi dava la possibilità di mantenere
la mia vita non mi sarei mai aspettata
che questa idea si sarebbe sviluppata in
questa maniera
l'undici di aprile 2015 è stata la prima
volta per il suo veto vivente e ci sono
volute cinque sei incontri 5 6 e 20
prima di creare la ricetta perfetta cioè
come oggi funziona il gioco è quanto
piace anche alle persone che giocano in
questi due anni ovviamente ho dovuto
capire che avevo bisogno di un'agenzia
di comunicazione che mi appoggiasse ho
dovuto capire che mi serviva una partita
iva per essere ovviamente in regola
ho capito che ho bisogno di uno staff di
collaboratori ho capito come dovevo fare
a pubblicizzare l'evento tutte quelle
cose che servono per una qualsiasi
macchina e ha cominciato a funzionare
io in questi due anni e mezzo ho portato
il credo vivente
90 2 volte in 30 città italiane per un
totale di 5.000 like sul social network
il gioco poi costa veramente poco questo
perché voglio che tutti possono giocare
lo studente squattrinato alla famiglia
che magari è numerosa quindi il prezzo
viene moltiplicato e poi voglio che
anche chi si è divertito una volta possa
tornare perché ogni volta il gioco lo
cambio le regole sono le stesse ma
cambiare le prove sulla base di questo
con una media di 300 persone all'evento
e io sono riuscito a fare giocare 25mila
persone
dunque io sono molto contento di tutto
ciò
con questo io sono riuscita anche a
salutare la mia agenzia
la mia azienda dove lavoravo ea fare del
comune dove vende il mio lavoro e ha
addirittura alla tenera età di 30 anni
io ho salutato la mia città ho fatto
valigie sono venuta sono andata a vivere
a roma perché un'altra mia grande
passione è quella della recitazione e
quindi ora faccio l'attrice è mai me lo
sarei immaginato quando ho iniziato
tutto questo quello che per me è
importante quello che importa
per me è mettere in circolo emozioni e
recitando lo faccio e scrivendo perché
amo anche la scrittura lo faccio e anche
con i giochi lo faccio perché le persone
che vengono a giocare sono veramente le
vedo credetemi se non ci credete venite
a giocare sono veramente felici e vivono
in questo modo il loro presente il loro
momento
insomma è gioco è una terapia e non sono
solo io a dirlo ma anche
scientificamente provato che il gioco
dona relax incanala mente stimolo alla
felicità perché stimola le endorfine che
sono appunto le sostanze che danno la
felicità
migliora la comunicazione aumenta la
creatività e non parliamo solo di
creatività che riguarda l'arte cioè vi
dà anche la possibilità di rivedere i
vostri problemi quotidiani e gestirli in
una maniera migliore trovare i nuovi
punti di vista e sviluppa l'intelligenza
e crea fiducia perché perché ad esempio
nelle famiglie numerose che vengono e
non solo per il genitore è un modo per
passare del tempo con il proprio figlio
ma si mette al suo livello
parla la stessa lingua e soprattutto da
parte di un bambino è bellissimo che ci
sia la mamma o al papà che trovano la
soluzione quindi li tiene ritiene
protetti anche rapito nell'antica grecia
diceva che l'uomo è più vicino a se
stesso quando raggiunge la serietà di un
bambino mentre gioca questo cosa
significa che quando noi giochiamo
riusciamo a permetterci di essere
veramente noi stessi
riusciamo ad entrare dentro di noi e non
siamo in quel momento l'uomo d'affari la
mamma la professoressa siamo noi stessi
e andiamo a toccare la parte più
profonda nella parte più profonda
c'è cenno ai bambini e il bello
dell'essere bambini e che si vanno a ri
stimolare quelle con le emozioni che
sono le principali la prima su tutte la
gioia e quando la gente vive la gioia ha
voglia di condividerla prima cosa quel
fare e condividerla con gli altri e alla
fine degli eventi io vedo le persone che
parlano tra di loro vanno via sorridendo
si raccontano mate com'è andata ma ti
ricordi quando abbiamo fatto questo e si
dimenticano che hanno avuto un cellulare
che probabilmente squillava per le
ultime due ore
io ad esempio adesso 16 messaggi in
dodici conversazioni perché perché non
ho voluto guardare il cellulare in
questo in questi undici minuti che sono
con voi e sono veramente contenta di non
averlo fatto perché è stato un momento
veramente speciale grazia
[Applauso]